so the death rate for the cool virus as
we are now talking about it thanks to a
suggestion from the audience I hope you
understood the cool virus cv the the
cool virus the death rate has been up to
3.4 percent by the whu-oh that now makes
it 34 times the death rate of the flu
and Donald Trump is simply denying that
this is the death rate because he has a
hunch and he's suggesting people take it
easy and not really worry too much about
it if you're wondering again why I'm
calling it the cool virus check out
yesterday's video on D monetization
here's Donald Trump calling it a false
number the death rate when speaking with
Sean Hannity on Fox News last night
here's we have a report today the global
death rate at 3.4 percent and a report
that the Olympics could be delayed your
reaction to that well I think the three
point four percent is really a false
number now this is just my hunch and but
based on a lot of conversations with a
lot of people that do this because a lot
of people will have this and it's very
mild they'll get better very rapidly
they don't even see a doctor they don't
even call it doctor you never hear about
those people so you can't put them down
in the in the category of the overall
population in terms of this Korona flu
and/or virus so you just can't do that
so if you know we have thousands or
hundreds of thousands imagine hearing
Donald Trump who knows nothing about
public health he knows nothing about
medicine say my hunch is that the World
Health Organization is wrong when
they've been right on everything so far
and he's been wrong when it comes to
this issue and then of course he refers
to cases that don't show up in the
statistics because they're not serious
that's true but that's the case with the
flu as well when we say the flu kills
0.1% and the cool virus kills 3.4
percent both have some uncertainty in
that there are very mild cases called
subclinical cases that never show up in
the denominator because you just think
you have a cold and you sit at home and
eventually it goes away that doesn't
change the relatively deadly nature of
this and also when Trump says
lots of people recover that's not
evidence that three-point-four is wrong
it's just evidence that there are other
people outside of the three-point-four
who are recovering and then in the
interview Trump see he takes this
demeanor where it's crazy to listen to
anyone other than him and obviously he
knows what's going on and it's flatly
dangerous it in his desperation to not
have political consequences to avoid
political repercussions from this Donald
Trump is just lying erratically and
desperately and we can't be listening to
what Donald Trump says on this we can't
be listening to what Mike Pence says on
this listen to the CDC but even they are
being affected by Trump cutting their
funding listen to the w-h-o the World
Health Organization I have a ton of
travel coming up I'm trying to figure
out what to do on the one hand you know
there's officially 150 cases in the u.s.
imagine that it's even a thousand
because uh we're not doing enough
testing to really know this canceling
domestic travel really makes sense for
me right now it feels like it's a bit
much especially because a lot of the
travel is work-related and they're good
opportunities again it's more likely I'd
get the flu anyway but of course cool
virus is 34 times more deadly at the
same time if the curve of new cases
continues to accelerate maybe it would
just be too stressful to travel and be
worried about it even if the risk is not
that great in the next eight weeks I'm
supposed to go to Miami Las Vegas and
Los Angeles California has now declared
an emergency or maybe it's LA County
maybe the entire state it's not only
about me I have people in my family who
are immunocompromised there's lots of
different factors I I genuinely don't
know what makes sense at this point and
back to our primary topic I know I don't
want to be listening to Donald Trump for
the advice the President and the Vice
President can't be listened to they
don't know what they're talking about
they're spreading this information it's
for political benefit he lies about
everything whether it's debt and deficit
crowd sizes whatever that stuff doesn't
have life or death consequences when he
lies about death rates and basic science
the repercussions can actually be life
or death in one tweet Barack Obama makes
more sense than Trump has made in total
on this Barack Oh
a tweet tweeted protect yourself and
your community from the virus with
common sense precautions wash your hands
stay home when sick and listen to the
CDC and local health authorities save
the masks for health care workers let's
stay calm
listen to the experts and follow the
science we also now have to worry about
trumpets on this issue 40% of the
population worships this guys every word
and won't take precautions and will be
involved in even riskier behavior
because of the things that Donald Trump
is telling them it's really really bad
real quick I want to tell you about a
YouTube channel called up flip they're
friends of our show you can check them
out by going to david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is down below
underneath the video every week up flip
publishes a new video where you get to
meet an entrepreneur learn about the
business they built see what it's like
to live a day in their shoes in that
business I love learning about small
business owners the steps they took to
become successful that's why I love the
content on up flip you'll get an
exclusive look at some really
fascinating businesses each entrepreneur
has many valuable insights and
strategies to share about how to build
and maintain a successful company I
would highly recommend their two-part
series on lean manufacturing which
itself is a really interesting concept
that's all about sort of minimizing
waste maximizing efficiency and up flip
breaks it all down you can get to their
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right below
this video make sure you subscribe to
their Channel and click that Bell icon
so you'll be notified when they upload
new videos